la problématique premièrement de la
valeur du diplôme et deuxièmement en
effet de l'isolément de la grande
précarité sociale qui touche les
étudiants aujourd'hui la valeur du
diplôme en lien bien évidemment avec la
qualité de la formation qui est donnée à
nos étudiants en ce moment et en lien
avec leur future insertion
professionnelle et j'aimerais vous
donner
pour compléter ce qui a été dit avant du
coup vous donne est différente
différentes précisions sur sur ce qui se
passe effectivement dans les facs là
dessus
il faut bien comprendre que la qualité
de notre formation est bien dégradée
parce distant ciel de notre formation
dès 2020 des deux mille sept cent mille
étudiants français et que et que se
distend ciel et est très dommageable
aujourd'hui il faut bien se rendre
compte et on l'avait dit encore une fois
c'est pour ça que je vous rappeler que
le travail on l'avait fait avec le
ministère et le travail institutionnel
depuis ben on le fait depuis longtemps
on l'avait dit la grosse le gros
chantier c'était les plateformes
numériques sur lesquels reposent
reposent ces ces différents cours cours
à distance et dans le prochain tu rends
le premier confinement on avait bien vu
les retards que pouvaient avoir les
universités à ce sujet on avait bien dit
que ça sera ça c'était la grosse le gros
chantier sur la rentrée 2021 est on est
on est malheureux de de remarquer qu' il
ya eu des progrès certes mais qu'il ya
encore énormément de choses à faire
quand on voit cette année encore au
second ce marché se met ce je pense je
parle même pas du 1er mai que à
l'université de lorraine
il ya des cours de tv où il ya 200
étudiants qui se connectent et ou du cou
en effet les ses 200 étudiants sont de
trop en fait tout simplement il ya trop
d'étudiants sûr sûr sûr sûr le même
groupe de télé et kalil inversement il y
avait il n'y avait pas assez de place
permise dans le sur la plateforme
numérique mise en mise à disposition
pour 1 pour 1 pour un cours à fin donc
on voit bien que que pour les étudiants
se distanciait dégradent la qualité de
l'information
on peut parler aussi bien évidemment des
professeurs qui sont parfois aussi eux
mêmes débordé par l'organisation de se
distancier donc donc pour compléter ce
qui a été dit je voulais vraiment quand
même vous donner ces exemples précis
[Musique]